يتصاعد القتال حول باخموت في اعقاب
السيطره الروسيه على سوليدار المجاوره
تستخدم القوات الاوكرانيه صواريخ جراند
سعيا لصد التقدم الروسي باتجاه المدينه
التي تقع على مسافه قريبه جدا جنوب غرب
سوليدار التي سقطت للتو في يد الجانب
الروسي ميدانيا تعد سوليدار مفتاح باخمود
وكلتاهما ميدانيا وفقا عسكريا تشكلان نقطه
الضعف الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه دونيتك التي
يستميت الروس لسيطره عليها كما ان بخمت
تحديدا نقطه تقاطع هامه لخطوط سكك حديديه
وطرق معبده وتعطي السيطره عليها فرصه
كبيره لروسيا للتمدد في مقاطعه
قياده العمليات الاوكرانيه قالت ان قواتها
تصدت لمحاولات روسيه للتقدم في محور
باخمود وقالت انها تحافظ على مواقعها
وتعزز خطوطها الدفاعيه في المدينه التي
استردتها من الروس قبل اسابيع قليله في
المقابله تحدثت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن
نجاحات في الضواحي الشماليه لباخمت وقال
بيانها اليومي ان عشارات الجنود
الاوكرانيين قتلوا فضلا عن تدمير عربات
قتاليه ومدرعات ما زال الجانب الروسي
منتشيا للسيطره التي اعلنها على سردار عبر
ميليشيا فاجنر التي تباها قائدها بقواته
وكفاءتها وتسليحها الفائق يتوقع ميدانيا
وفقا خبراء عسكريين ان تتحرك عناصر فاجنر
من سوريا هي الان تتمركز جنوب المدينه
ويتوقع ان تهاجم ايضا من الشمال لان
الدفاعات الاوكرانيه متاهبه جنوبا
نشرت القوات الاوكرانيه والصور لمقاتلين
شي من حلفاء لها كانوا يتصداون لجنود من
فاجنر حاولوا التسلل الى مواقع الجيش
الاوكراني جنوب الشرقيه ضخمه التي مازال
الاوكرانيون ينفون صحه انباء تتحدث عن
وقوعها تحت الحصار